the market continues to plummet as the
Chinese coronavirus locks people idle in
their homes for weeks at a time and the
global economy grinds to a halt we will
compare the pandemic to the left-wing
policy agenda and see if we can tell the
difference then a new study suggests
that the spread of the virus could have
been reduced by as much as 95% if the
Chinese government had acted to stop it
rather than to cover it up of course
instead of reporting on that study the
US mainstream media is simply parroting
the communist regimes propaganda finally
the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
what a week does it has it been a long
week for you it's felt like a long week
for me I was trying to recap everything
that's happened this week and I realized
there is a striking similarity between
everything we've been seeing in the
markets in policy from our leaders and
in the agenda that the left wing has
wanted in this country for a hundred
years we'll get to that in a second
first I got to thank our friends over at
light stream you know especially these
days people might be putting a lot of
stuff on their credit cards those credit
card interest rates are so so high it's
very important if you've if you're gonna
carry around some debt you need a low
interest rate okay because otherwise
you're gonna be throwing money away it's
very easy with a credit card
consolidation loan from light stream to
get those rates down lower rates are as
low as five point nine five percent APR
with Auto pay that is much lower than
the national average interest rate for
credit cards which is over twenty
percent APR okay you can get a loan from
five thousand to a hundred thousand
dollars with absolutely no fees
I love light stream talk about a company
that is really coming in in the clutch
right now okay people are putting a lot
of a lot of stuff into the future all
right they're putting a lot of stuff on
credit cards don't throw your money away
especially when it's important to keep
it so right now you can apply today get
a special interest rate discount save
even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to light stream comm
slash Knowles came to wles that is lig
HTS tream tom / knoll subject to credit
approval rate includes 0.50% auto pay
discount terms and conditions apply and
offers to subject to change without
notice
visit live stream comm / Knowles for
more information the Dow Jones
Industrial Average has dropped another
1,300 points yesterday the S&P 500 lost
seven trillion dollars in value over the
past couple of weeks the economy around
the world and in the United States is
grinding to a halt store shelves are
empty there are food shortages at
supermarkets you cannot buy toilet paper
countless people are losing their jobs
we just heard from Marriott just one
company right Marriott the hotel chain
they laid off tens of thousands of
people a couple of days ago the
government is now sending checks
directly to people who are not working
who can't find work or who have been
told to quarantine we are not flying
anywhere right we're not getting on
airplanes we're not traveling anywhere
we're barely driving places it occurs to
me that this is a OCS dream this is the
green flu deal that's what we're living
through it's a nice little preview you
know I've tried to keep a normal
attitude during all of this I've tried
not to let the panic run away from me
afraid to see the glass half-full
sometimes when everyone else is losing
their mind and running around and saying
we're all gonna die
the or we're all gonna die also said
we're all gonna die but I say we're all
gonna die because someday we're all
gonna die not because we're all gonna
die from this virus the coronavirus
chaos is nothing compared to what the
green New Deal would do to our society
and I'm sort of glad that we get a
little preview of this so that people
stop talking seriously about this policy
proposal think about what look around
you of what you're experiencing now the
joblessness the being confined to your
little apartment you're not being able
to travel you're not being able to buy
certain things at the stores you're not
being able to work the green New Deal
would be that times a zillion what what
is the green New Deal do do you remember
this this is not some fringe left-wing
policy proposal this was something being
proposed by someone that the chairman of
the DNC says is the future of the
Democratic Party
it was then endorsed by I think
virtually every single Democratic
presidential candidate and many many
prominent members of the Senate but the
green New Deal
outlaws air travel green New Deal
outlaws most automobiles so it severely
reduces car travel the green New Deal
outlaws about ninety percent of American
energy so right away the minute that
that goes into effect the economy
completely grinds to a halt right you
can't do things in the
me without energy think about don't
think just about the oil industry
fracking don't think about that think
about also every single industry that
uses those things namely all of them
according to the green New Deal people
would receive direct handouts from the
government for not working see at least
now
under the current bailouts that are
being considered the government is going
to send you a check because it's a
crisis because you can't work because
the government has stopped you from
working under the green New Deal
Americans would receive those checks
even if they don't want to work for
people who this is the language that AOC
had used originally people who are
unable or unwilling to work this sucker
you just like don't want to and then you
get a check from the government and it's
not just a one-time check it's a
perpetual check and the green New Deal
would cost 93 trillion dollars so the
S&P loses seven trillion over the last
few weeks that's pretty bad now multiply
that by 13 that's where you get the cost
of the green New Deal so while we're
living through our green flu deal let
that be a preview of what happens if
very mainstream leftist policy proposals
actually would be put into action what
that would look like for our economy
this would be nothing but a little order
of a little amuse-bouche for that dinner
of the green New Deal you you ain't seen
nothing yet
if you think this is bad just just wait
if anything good were to come of this
issue you know it would be causing
people to face these economic realities
alright I I mentioned on the show in the
early days of this virus that that
people sort of enjoy the free cap you
know that people they like the danger
they like the uncertainty they like that
we're all in this together they like
that it's a little different that's
shaking them out of their monotonous
lives it's it's like when the power goes
out in a snowstorm and everyone pretends
to be really upset about it but actually
you kind of like it you it's fun it's
something new that only lasts for about
a day or two
and then people start really not to like
it okay you you get sick of the
speculation you get sick of constantly
talking about it you know it's not so
fun when people are losing their jobs
I know people multiple people whose
paychecks have been cut in half already
these are people who never thought that
the economy grinding to a halt would
touch them that only touches the little
people you know the people who are
working those jobs they're really
vulnerable but it doesn't touch all of
us yes it does
it touches everybody when the economy
grinds to a halt it has long
long-standing effects very very quickly
I know a lot of I mean I know a lot of
bartenders and waiters who are now
completely out of work but even people
who are lawyers their salaries cut in
half even people who are working in
education their salaries cut in half all
right that's the economic reality and of
course it makes sense it's you don't
need an economist to tell you why this
is true if everybody stops working
there's gonna be less money it's not
like the economy is this abstract
concept but it's also a very tangible
practical concept if I work more I'll
get a get more stuff I'll be more
prosperous I'll be able to eat better
and dress better and move better and if
I work less I won't be able to do that
because money doesn't just come from
magic doesn't just come from nowhere it
comes from the productivity that we all
have so if we all stop being productive
guess what happens all that wealth goes
away this is the economic reality
I loved Mara gay that New York Times
editorial number who she she said on the
Brian Williams show on MSNBC that Mike
Bloomberg could give every American a
million dollars for the amount of money
that he spent on his campaign and that
was off by six orders of magnitude but
it actually shows us the left's
understanding of economics because when
the left talks about money in public
policy whether it's the presidential
candidates or whether it's a commentator
or it's a New York Times editorial board
member it's all the same to them
seriously they think a million and a
billion and a trillion it's all the same
it all ends in iliyan right it's all got
some zeros after
what's the big deal Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren on the campaign trail
when they're proposing these 52 trillion
dollar policy proposals Elizabeth
Warren's plan when you add it all up for
health care was 52 trillion dollars they
said how are you gonna pay for that she
said oh come on it'll be easy don't
worry come on that's a dumb question
we'll figure it out guess what it's a
lot easier to pay for something that's
52 million dollars than 52 trillion
dollars but they don't think of that
they just think oh it's money we're rich
we're rich well we'll have the money to
pay for it well guess what if the
economy grinds to a halt we're not going
to be rich for very long and speaking of
our elected representatives like Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren the woo
flew the the wool banach plague has now
infected elected representatives so
rather than being at the tail end of
this thing we might only be at the very
beginning we'll get to what that means
in a second because I actually think
there's a silver lining to this too
first up I've got to thank our friends
over at Bambi it's very important to
have a good HR team especially now when
people are experiencing a little shift
in cash flow people are a little worried
they don't know what their future looks
like they don't know what the future the
business looks like seriously so many
problems that plague businesses happen
because they don't take care of their
h/r issues HR issues can kill your
business especially in cases of wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations and by
the way HR salaries are not that cheap
the average is $70,000 $70,000 per year
but Bambi ba MBE was specifically
created for small businesses you get a
dedicated HR manager all for just $99 a
month I know it sounds unbelievable but
it's an amazing amazing service your
dedicated HR manager can talk on phone
email real-time chat there are just
tremendous Bambi calm / Michael mi CH AE
L right now go there schedule your free
HR audit that is Bambi comm slash
Michael B am to the B EE comm / mi CH AE
L okay so now we've got public officials
who have been infected with the virus
before this we just heard they'd been
exposed Ted Cruz
self-quarantine then I was maybe had to
self quarantine because senator Cruz met
a guy who had been tested positive and
then I obviously saw senator Cruz in the
same room this isn't like that these
elected officials now actually have the
virus that's representatives Mario
diaz-balart and ben mcadams diaz-balart
is a Republican from Florida and Ben
McAdams is a Democrat from Utah they
both tested positive yesterday and so
now they're going to have to quarantine
and live with the virus other public
figures who have the virus Tom Hanks
Norm Macdonald the comedian has taken to
calling coronavirus Tom Hanks disease
THD Tom Hanks tested positive for it
week or two ago idris elba the actor
tested positive for it Justin Trudeau's
wife tested positive for it
interestingly I don't think Justin
Trudeau has but Justin Trudeau's wife
has so anyway there are these well-known
figures in public life who now have the
corona virus this actually might be a
great opportunity to get some
perspective on it I think some people
right now the initial reaction is that
celebrities having the Wu flu is a
terrible thing because now it's gonna be
magnified people are going to be even
more nervous and neurotic and freaked
out even more than they already were I
think the opposite is true I think
really if the statistics are right and
all the people who have been infected
are not going to face serious
complications from it or death or
anything like that god forbid that
seeing these public figures that we all
know have the virus and then hopefully
just recover quickly will be a great
thing to ease the public make us realize
we're not all gonna die from this thing
we're not all gonna be hospitalized
we're not even all going to have severe
symptoms and that's just for the people
who will eventually get the virus anyway
it might be a nice way to pump the
brakes on all of the hysteria because I
think people are sick of it I think we
enjoyed it for a few days
we won't admit that we enjoyed it but we
enjoyed it it was kind of fun it was
weird it was it was so unexpected one
sandal
time thing and now people are really
sick of this people are really sick of
being quarantined people are really sick
of being told where to go and what to do
people are really sick of having no food
on the shelves like we're living in
Havana Cuba or something and we need to
get back to normal as quickly as
possible
now the mainstream media of course are
not helping this at all the mainstream
media are not reporting on any relevant
data when it comes to this virus the
mainstream media are not doing anything
to quell people's fears actually what
they're doing because they're too
childish and partisan to even report on
the virus itself they are instead
focusing on an aspect of Chinese
propaganda and parroting that the
Chinese government is now saying it's
racist to call the virus Chinese I
wonder why they're saying that we talked
about this a little bit on this show
yesterday of course China doesn't want
any blame and they know that leftists in
America will carry their water for them
so now the media are are parroting this
line they're completely failing to do
their job during this pandemic so
they're asking is it racist to point out
that the virus is Chinese I won't get
into too many examples of this we did it
yesterday John Nolte on Breitbart has
listed 53 examples of the mainstream
media calling the virus the Chinese
corona virus or the Wuhan virus before
they decided to be parrots for Chinese
propaganda and say that that's racist go
check that out it's really really funny
the reason I bring it up is over the
last day president Trump has now
addressed discharge himself and we are
seeing peak Trump grade-a this is why we
elected you Trump he is asked by some
reporter I've never heard of if it is
racist to refer to the Chinese origins
of this virus Trump does not give an
inch why do you keep calling this the
Chinese virus there are reports of
dozens of
incidents of bias against Chinese
Americans in this country your own age
secretary eServices he does not use this
term because ethnicity does not cause
the virus why are you using this
actually comes from Jamie it's not
racist at all now let it off it comes
from China
that's why comes from China I want to be
accurate yeah please John I have a great
I have great love for all of the people
from our country but as you know China
tried to say at one point maybe this
stuff now that it was caused by American
soldiers that can't happen it's not
gonna happen not as long as I'm
president it comes from China great
answer to big problems with that
reporters question first of all she says
viruses don't have an ethnicity that's
true but they do have a nationality
viruses do come from places and the
Chinese coronavirus came from China just
like the West Nile virus came from the
West Nile just like Ebola comes from the
Ebola River just like the Spanish flu
came through Spain and actually didn't
come from Spain but Spain gave it it's a
popular character so they do have
nationalities this one has an
exclusively it's not even like the
Spanish flu where you say well it
started here and then it went here and
then it became really a big problem here
this virus just comes from China it
became a big problem in China the whole
reason that we're dealing with it as
kiss China didn't deal with it it's a
Chinese virus that's the first problem
with her question the second problem
with her question is how offensive it is
to Americans because her premise is that
if you refer to this as the Chinese
virus then Americans are just gonna
start beating Chinese people in the
street that's what she said she said
there are already examples of hostility
toward Chinese people why would you make
it worse by calling them a Chinese virus
as though Americans are just waiting we
are seething with bigotry and hatred we
oh give me one any excuse to just become
violent against people of other races Oh
president please tell us where the virus
comes from so we can just become beasts
start beating people over the head are
you kidding me what do you think of your
countrymen we are the least bigoted most
open and tolerant society ever ever in
the whole history of the world and this
reporter looks at her countrymen and
says oh my gosh they're all animals
they're bigots they're they're beasts
that if you if you they're also idiots
and they don't realize the virus comes
from China so if you tell these dumb
violent rubes where the virus comes from
they're gonna start clubbing people over
the head you know I think that if you
took the average American it would
probably be much more polite and have a
much better view of the world and
probably much better manners than most
DC reporters okay if we're trying to
compare people here so that was that
lady I don't know who that was then
another lady another reporter asks
President Trump a more hilarious version
of the same question she asks if it's
racist to call the virus come flu at
least one White House official will use
the term come flu referring to the fact
that this virus started in China is that
acceptable is it wrong are you worried
that that having this virus being talked
about as as a Chinese virus but would
you can use the facts a the time again a
person at the White House
you used it to run flu flu and do you
think using the term Chinese virus
Beckett's asian-americans no no I think
they probably would agree with it 100%
it comes from China there's nothing not
to agree okay how about the last
question here he is here is Trump doing
the thing he does best which is he just
plays with those mainstream media
reporters like a little marionette on
strings
so she says somebody some unnamed person
in your administration called the virus
come flu
heaven forfend grab my pearls made a
pretty funny pun about the virus oh no
it's the end of the world what it's
pretty much David Duke didn't that
like Richard Spencer's working for you
because they made a pun or something and
so Trump is really good he doesn't laugh
out loud
he keeps the straight face he goes who
said this and she goes why don't know so
it highlights first of all that these
people don't have good information
anyway they're just passing along
innuendo and insinuation they're not
even going to say it was that person it
was that staffer so he goes okay all
right he they move on past that one he
goes and what did they call it as if
President Trump hadn't heard it the
first time cuz he does it with a burr
vagueness trayvis what did they call it
and she starts to repeat her question he
goes no no no just say the term no you
say the term come flu yeah holy Kong flu
yes come flu so he gets this mainstream
media reporter to utter the phrase come
flu to the President on national
television multiple times and then once
he's gotten her to say it enough times
come flu and you just you can't you
can't keep up the mainstream narrative
when you actually hear this because with
the mainstream narrative is the White
House staffers are using racial insults
and attacking their fellow countrymen
who are Asian and it's bigoted and it's
awful and might as well be the n-word
right and that's kind of the insinuation
there but then the reality of it is is
come flu it's just funny just funny term
to refer to this Chinese coronavirus and
so he gets her to say it and then
anybody who's watching it just thinks
okay that what are we angry about now
what are we supposed to they what they
wouldn't even be able to be angry
because they would be too busy laughing
and I think President Trump certainly
was laughing on the inside during that
and probably laughed about it a little
bit afterward not to put too fine a
point on it it is obviously not racist
to talk about where the viruses come
from this is 100% the fault of the
Chinese government we will explain
exactly how and exactly how much better
our lives would be how much lower the
death rate would be how much lower the
hospitalization rate would be how much
better our economy would be doing if
China had just dealt with this in the
first place but first we got to thank
our friends the Benham brothers what is
the secret to building a business
is it just like hustle hustle hustle
until you die is it success no matter
the cost is it having a bad marriage is
it broken promises is it lies is it
missed ball games doesn't have to be
this way some people will tell you
that's what you have to do but it's not
true you can grow a business without
sacrificing your family and your
character or you don't have to be the
caricature of the evil wicked ruthless
businessman that you see from Hollywood
okay I want to tell you about the Benham
Brothers the Benham brothers have over a
dozen businesses including a real estate
empire that spans 35 states and they
didn't have to sell their soul for it
all right that name might even ring a
bell the Benham brothers were slated for
a reality TV show on HGTV and they were
cancelled because of their commitment to
conservative values so-called business
coaches tell you that your life has to
take a backseat to your hustle David and
Jason Benham are proof that that's a lie
just this week the venom Brothers
launched their new course expert
ownership to celebrate the launch of
their new course they're offering 15%
off to new members you can check out a
preview of the course and take advantage
of that discount over at Benham brothers
comm / knowles can or wles that is benh
am ben ham Benham brothers dot-com /
Knowles canna wles head on over there to
check out the course president Trump is
absolutely right to blame the Chinese
for this the Chinese are 100% at fault
the government of China is what I'm
talking about by the way I'm not talking
about the billion people living in China
I'm talking about the government the
Communist Party it is their fault we
should send the Chinese government the
bill for all of the economic chaos if
they don't pay the bill
we should plunder their wealth until we
are made at least financially whole for
this there's no way to be made totally
whole think of all of the deaths think
of all of the hospitalizations think
even beyond that of just the missed
moments people's graduations are being
canceled people's weddings are being
canceled people's baptisms are being
canceled moments are very very important
in life ruined because of the damn
Chinese Communists we should take all of
their wealth
we should these people the Chinese
government deserves to be taken out
like Old Yeller for what they have done
in this crisis okay nobody is reporting
on this but there is a new study that
just came out from the University of
Southampton research found that if
interventions in China could have been
conducted one week or two weeks or three
weeks earlier how much do you think the
chaos that has been caused by this could
have been reduced how much do you think
this spread could have been reduced if
they reacted instead of covering it up
if they reacted to stop it one week
earlier the spread would have been
reduced by 66% if they had stopped
covering it up and actually acted to
stop the virus two weeks earlier the
spread would have been reduced by 86%
and if those bastards in the Chinese
government had acted to stop this virus
instead of covering it up three weeks
earlier the spread would have been
reduced 95 percent 95 percent you
wouldn't have even felt it we now have
some deaths in America luckily the death
rate is relatively quite low you have
more significant number of deaths in
Italy and Iran and it's spreading all
over the world 95 percent of that could
have been wiped away
if those horrible horrible people in the
Communist Chinese government had acted
to stop it instead what they did was
they pretended it wasn't real they
punished whistleblowers doctors who were
talking about the spread of this virus
there they would not intervene to do it
and now the most appalling of all most
galling of all the left in America the
mainstream media and elected
representatives are carrying water for
that government the government that
killed people the government that
destroyed the global economy the
government that intentionally allowed
this virus to spread around the world
the left and the mainstream media are
parroting their propaganda the Chinese
government is writing the talking points
for CNN at this point okay
ABB's
they disgraceful absolutely disgusting
stuff we need to be very clear about it
so when we use terms like the wool
banach plague or kung flu or Chop fluey
or the lung past sicken or any of the
other terms that are you know like
pretty funny
look it's somehow like a week later
they're still fairly amusing not only
are they amusing it's very important
because the Chinese government right now
as always has been trying to dodge
responsibility now they're actually
trying to put responsibility on the
United States incredibly and we need to
make sure that doesn't happen and if
that means that some of our useful idiot
friends in the mainstream media want to
call everybody racist for stating simple
facts about a virus that's perfectly
fine we cannot lose the narrative here
ok I hope you've had a chance to see
some of the new show that we launched
this week called all-access live over a
daily wire.com that is the first episode
ben shapiro and the daily wire god-king
jeremy boring kicked it off on Monday
and then Jeremy and I did it on Tuesday
we're gonna be doing episodes the rest
of this week at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m.
Pacific it's pretty what you know look
we're all quarantined now we're all you
know kind of locked at home but it's a
fun way to hang out talk to you guys
hear from you guys and it's like it's
like we're all in a room you know my my
speech speaking tour was canceled this
semester because of the Wuhan virus
because pretty much every major speaking
event was canceled for the next few
months and so this is one way that we
can all hang out and talk and it's very
cool look we wouldn't have been able to
do this even ten years ago but here in
America land of opportunity technology
has grown so great that we can do that
now so we've had to accelerate the show
launch in order to bring you this
content please let us know what you
think of it we will help you get through
this quarantine you will help us get
through this quarantine we'll be a
stronger country for it I hope if you're
around at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
tonight join us on the all-access live
show over daily wired.com watch the live
stream and join the chat because I've
got to tell you before we cut to the
mailbag there there is one woman on the
internet who's really convinced me that
it's all gonna be okay you know she's
convinced me what I'm gonna do in my
quarantine and I think she's
you should consider taking her advice as
well this is a woman who was interviewed
during a storm outside of Charlotte
North Carolina and she explained I think
exactly the attitude we should all have
well finally sit around and cook some
soup thing eat bread and desserts and
just get all fat and sassy that's what
I'm gonna do can't get me down mayor
Garcetti can't get me down quarantine
I'm just gonna sit around you know maybe
make some soups eat some breads and
desserts and just get all fat and sassy
all right head on over to Daly wire.com
we will be right back with the mailbag
first question from Martin hi Michael
any figures on the infection rates and
death of other viruses doing the rounds
this particular year and is coronavirus
God's Way of saying borders are good for
you you Schmucks well God is a Jew so he
might use the word Schmucks the first
part of your question yes many many many
more people at least according to the
official statistics have had the flu
this year and many many many many more
people will die of the flu this year
then so far from the corona virus in the
United States we'll see if that holds up
true they're all telling us that the day
after tomorrow the whole world is going
to implode but that date keeps getting
pushed forward so that's certainly the
case the the virus is more contagious
than the flu but it's less contagious
than other public health issues we've
had in the past Zika is one of the
examples so you know it would seem to be
in this wheelhouse we don't really have
good data at this point but the data
that we have are either inconclusive or
they're contradictory but nothing is
suggesting to us that the world is going
to end as for the question about open
borders or not this is a big wake up
call on the borders you know the left is
telling us a lot of contradictory things
when it comes to this but their left is
telling us that we need to have totally
open borders walls are evil walls don't
work and also quarantine yourself within
walls otherwise you're going to destroy
the country
so apparently walls have the ability to
stop the spread of the plague but walls
can't do anything else they can't they
don't actually work but they're actually
so important that you need to lock
yourself within for very small walls
that doesn't make a lot of sense the
other contradiction they have during all
of this is when we point out that maybe
people shouldn't eat bats
a been made this point yesterday said
yeah maybe don't eat bats and then if we
don't eat bats we won't get these kind
of diseases and the left is furious
about this they say how dare you that's
culturally insensitive that's
politically incorrect that's racist I
don't know how it's racist species list
maybe but not racist and I think been
made the point the left tells you you
can't eat meat that it's immoral to eat
meat so it's so immoral to eat meat it's
immoral to drink
like what key and Phoenix told us but
it's very good to eat bats
I think bats are meeting if you're gonna
eat meat by the way bats would should
not be at the top of your list of course
the reason they're doing this is the
left just wants to take cheap shots
because they don't like their own
country and they would rather carry
water for communists then then be fair
to their own countrymen from Bennett
Deer destroyer of the libs and austere
political podcaster I'm a high school
student who has recently received a nice
long break because of the whoo flu so
I've had some extra time on my hands the
other day while polishing up on my early
Hungarian history a question occurred to
me is there any hope for a return to the
fundamental nation-state like those seen
in Europe during much of the second
millennium how can we go back or will we
just have to bugger on through this new
secular system of world government until
the end of days thanks for your opinion
great question
I think people misunderstand this a
little bit probably not you but a lot of
people do because they don't teach
European history anymore in schools the
nation-state is we understand it today
is a relatively new invention it comes
from the Peace of Westphalia in 1648
before that that sort of ended the 30
Years War you had the Wars of Religion
but you also had Empire in much larger
number you had the Holy Roman Empire you
had various empires throughout the West
and those are two different forms of
government the nation-state
is a different form of government than
Empire which includes many different
Empire includes many different
territories many different people's the
nation-state much less so and now we saw
the nation-state grow and grow and grow
throughout all the way up until say the
middle of the 20th century then after
the Second World War
nationalism got a very bad name and so
you saw a move away from the
nation-state this gave you the growth of
say the European Union for instance
other international transnational
supranational organizations that really
constitute more of an empire than
anything resembling a Federal Republic
now this kind of Empire is very
different than the old empires of Europe
the old empires of Europe were religious
think about the Holy Roman Empire or the
Roman Empire
before that the actual Roman Empire now
we've got secular Empire so the EU is
not it's not the representative of
Western Christendom
it's the representative of secular
liberalism and so it just looks very
very different than the old empires and
the question we have now is is there a
future for that is there a future for
secular globalist modernist liberal
Empire I don't think there is I think
brexit was one of the first shots
against that people people don't like
being told what to do by a bunch of
secular bureaucrats and Brussels and
then I think this Wuhan virus could be
the final nail in the coffin we're now
seeing a return to the nation-state and
the reason for that is your amazon erode
a great book about this called the
virtue of nationalism which is the
nation's state kind of uniquely in
history manages to balance freedom and
order so Empire is really good at order
right it the Roman Empire kept the order
kept the peace but it's not great on
freedom because in order to affect that
order
you have to trample on people's
liberties to use our terms for it now on
the other end you get freedom freedom
you know say very small Republic's or
individual communities or individual
states are really good at freedom but
they're not really good at order and so
if you don't have order eventually
you're gonna lose that freedom to the
nation-states kind of unique thing
between say the city-state or very small
territories and Empire where you can
balance freedom and order and that's why
I think it's coming back into fashion
and I think that's probably a very good
thing from Paula to end the toilet paper
shortage should we finally put the New
York Times to good use Thanks
I would never degrade my body by
touching it with the New York Times okay
I cannot do that sorry not going to
happen next question from Jeffrey hi
Michael I always hear a lot of people on
the Left claiming unemployment is only
low because people have to work two jobs
because their wages are so low do you
have any insight yeah
yes people just don't know how
unemployment works I guess AOC I think
made that point year or two ago she said
yeah well the only reason the
unemployment rate is lows because people
have two jobs if you have one job you
will be counted as employed having two
jobs doesn't cut the unemployment rate
in half it doesn't affect the
unemployment rate it's about whether you
are employed or not not how many jobs
you have so so no there's absolutely no
merit to that observation from Moe
master Knowles do you think it is
possible that Bernie will run as an
independent when he loses the Democratic
nomination or will he fall in line and
give Abidin his coveted blessing I don't
think Bernie will run as an independent
Bernie is already winding down his
campaign he's apparently turned off
online ads that's not confirmed but
there are reports about that he was
asked about his campaign the other day
and he snapped at a reporter and said
I'm trying to deal with an effing global
crisis okay I don't have time for these
questions so he's a little ornery about
that he went back to Vermont allegedly
to reassess the campaign so it looks
like he's winding it down I only he's
gonna run again and also look he rolled
over last time right for all of Bernie's
I'm a hard-charging fighter he rolled
over in 2016 when they stole the
election from him and he endorsed
Hillary so he'll probably do that again
Bernie's career is marked by yelling and
screaming and saying that you're
different than everybody and we need a
radical change and then ultimately not
really doing anything I don't think
Bernie really wants to do anything
frankly I don't think you would want to
be President he doesn't want
responsibility he's never had
responsibility in his life the guy
didn't get a job until he was
practically 40 all right he got evicted
from his a from his apartment when he
was a young man in Burlington got
evicted he got evicted with his son
because he didn't want to have to get a
job and pay his bills so yeah I don't
think he even really seriously wants to
be the leader of the free world he's a
revolutionary yelling at people from the
outside but when it comes down to it
he'll roll over from Kelly do you think
this quarantine people staying home
cooking for themselves schooling their
children well
some people back to a family centered
life or will we go back to our modern
ways as soon as the gates are opened
again you've been my constant companion
this year into comfort in troubled times
thank God for you that's very kind thank
you thanks for tuning in I would like to
think that this will bring people back
to traditional ways but I don't think
three days of sitting at home and
ordering takeout is going to do that
unfortunately I I don't think that this
bizarre quarantine experience is going
to do that I think it's much more akin
to the lights going out during a
snowstorm at which when the lights go
out during a snowstorm it doesn't bring
people back to traditional family values
part of the reason for that too is that
in some ways the lights going out has a
better chance of bringing you back to a
traditional family values because the
power goes out so you can't watch TV you
can't just be on your phone you can't
just be sitting alone in your room on
Instagram you've got to be with people
talking to people candle lights on maybe
you read a book maybe you play a board
game
maybe you just hang out in this case
we're stuck at home but we're probably
just as socially isolated as ever or
maybe we're more socially isolated part
of that is to most people don't live
with their families as at least young
professionals they they live truly alone
so if anything I think it's going to
isolate people more sorry for the to
leave you on a down note there but if we
want to restore family values in America
it's gonna be a little tougher than that
from Jason can trump sign an executive
order mandating that Mike Bloomberg must
send every American 1 million dollars
Wow that's an amazing number and it's
amazing because it's true I guess he can
man you know if if we all lived in MSNBC
world then absolutely Trump could sign
that executive order and I look frankly
in America today probably he could sign
the executive order because we're
totally fine confiscating wealth from
anybody I mean that's pretty much the
Democratic Party platform but in order
to make the math work you know we'd have
to be living in MSNBC land and the big
rock candy mountain from Paxton hey
Michael I believe you have mentioned
for that you had an atheist phase in
college but later converted back to
Christianity what argument were changed
was the tipping point that caused you to
go back to God the ontological argument
simple answer it was a much more
involved process than that and it's
funny now because the ontological
argument is not even the best argument
for God but it was the one that got me I
think it's a sort of whimsical argument
it's a very charming argument and even
Bertrand Russell great logician and a
very famous atheist infamous atheist
couldn't find the logical flaw in it so
that one got me and the ontological
argument is very simple it goes
something like this
God is the maximally great being he's
got all the great making characteristics
none of the corrupting ones it's not
impossible that God exists and it's
better to exist then not to exist so if
God has all the great making
characteristics then God must exist it's
so unsatisfying for people and yet I
found it very charming there are better
versions of the ontological argument
than that particularly the modal
ontological argument but anyway that one
got me so it's worth checking out I
think
and then CS Lewis mere christianity
talking and noticing that all the
smartest people at the very very
smartest people I knew believed in God
believe in Christianity and that was
kind of curious to me and then exploring
the much deeper intellectual tradition
and only after that only after I had
sort of ass waged my hubris and
intellectual pride only then did the
spiritual component kick in and that's
probably the more important one but it
was a long process like Hemingway says
things happen gradually then suddenly
from Anna I Michael I was listening to
the all-access lockdown episode two and
you and the god-king talked about free
will in the examples of an addict or a
homosexual as a young person who's been
addicted to nicotine for over ten years
that level of addiction is still a
choice I know that I could stop tomorrow
it would be hard but I could do it I
have the choice or the freewill to make
that choice I think that every
individual is born with certain
temptations that challenge us more than
those same temptations challenge others
from drugs to sexual acts and even
homosexuality I absolutely believe that
we have the choice to control room
from those temptations and that's how
and why we are held accountable by God
could you expand on your opinion of this
thanks yes my opinion is you sound like
an addict you said that just that key
phrase you said I've been addicted to
nicotine for ten years but I could stop
anytime I know a lot of addicts who say
they could stop any time and the
majority of them cannot stop at any time
maybe you can maybe you're the exception
the point I think still remains
addiction makes it very hard to exercise
your will
now Jeremy went to it an extreme and he
said I don't believe in free will now I
don't agree with that I certainly do
believe in free will I believe in free
will I think more than most people do
probably however part of the issue with
our free will is that when we abuse our
free will and we sin or if you want to
use the kind of secular analogy here we
let's say we get into an addiction then
it becomes harder and harder to exercise
our will because we come become
habituated to sin and it's it's why it
this is the trouble with virtue is we
think of virtue it's just this abstract
thing we do we help an old lady cross
the street
good we've virtually do it more and more
so when you freely choose to engage in
virtue and you freely choose to do a
good thing then it becomes easier to do
the next good thing it becomes a habit
and then you live a virtuous life when
you abuse your free will to do a bad
thing to sin to be to do vice then it
becomes much easier to commit the next
vice to sin more to go further down that
rabbit hole becomes much harder to pull
yourself out and so you can throw off
the responsibility and say well I'm an
addict well I'm I can't help myself but
and then that's true but you've also
freely made the choice to practice those
vices so it's a complex relationship the
way I would describe the relationship
between freewill and grace is like two
people dancing a waltz it's a
relationship that you can't separate and
so of course we must have
freewill in order for anything that we
know about ourselves in our society and
our God to be correct we must have free
will but the reality of temptation
reality of sin has to be real as well
and grace most importantly has to be
real as well how's that for a way to end
the week hope you all survived
quarantine I'll still be around but I'll
certainly see you if not before then on
Monday
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show see then just get all fat
and sassy
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
whanau ski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen